michael jordan is the one who's going to
posthumously induct him into the hall of
fame this weekend
and it was a beautiful piece on this
very subject matter
by espn senior writer jackie mcmullen
called the last communication between
michael jordan
and kobe bryant and jackie kind enough
to join us right here on this edition of
the rich eisen show how are you jackie
hey rich it's been a while it has been
like i've seen your wife more recently
then
actually there's a lot of people who say
that uh because it's true and
and i i appreciate that she sends her
best to you too jackie so
um i'll give you the floor um people who
may not have seen your piece it is
beautiful
and it strikes at the heart of the the
um
the sadness but also
i guess uh commemoration that this
weekend is
for kobe bryant i'll give you the floor
on
on this story about jordan and the the
final communication between he and
kobe well i think rich
those of us close to the game knew how
much kobe reached out to michael but i'm
not sure that
general fans did and particularly
near the end of his career kobe was
talking to jordan all the time calling
him at all hours of day and night
and you know michael was the first to
admit at times it was kind of annoying
even because he had
made the famous proclamation hey if you
ever need anything give me a call
and boy did kobe call again and again
and again and again and so that's how
this relationship became so strong
michael's very different from kobe in in
this one way
and you were around michael so you know
this he
wasn't big on letting everybody in on
what he was up to
he very much kept it to himself he
didn't court
uh journalists the way kobe did kobe was
brilliant at it i remember when kobe
passed
how many of my colleagues were like well
i was really close with him everybody
felt like he was kobe had that gift to
make you all feel like you were on the
inside
right he was good at that jordan much
more private so i think that's
why we didn't know the depth of this
relationship
i did uh one of the final pieces i did
on kobe was
examining all the role models that he
had all the people that
he looked to to become the best that he
could be and including michael jackson
you know he was he was tapping into
michael jackson and asking him
you know he went up to neverland and
asked him about uh how he learned to
you know do smooth criminal and michael
jackson showed him films of fred astaire
and he said you've got to learn from all
the greats go out and learn from all the
greats
and so that's what that's what kobe did
he called larry byrd on the golf course
you know he very famously went down and
spent a weekend with the kim olajuwon so
he could learn
how to play out of the post he hit up dr
j and of course
magic and jerry west and all the great
uh lakers that
he was around as a young player and uh
and of course he hit up jordan and i
think uh
jordan to him was who he wanted to be he
wanted to be better than jordan
and jordan claimed to view him as his
little brother and i thought the most uh
you know this piece that i did the other
day
the thing that i thought was most
interesting while the the final text is
heartbreaking for all of us right
the thing that i that jumped out at me
that michael said was
i think kobe was mentally tougher than
me how many people can say that
and jordan i don't imagine he'd say it
about anybody else
and i said what do you mean by that and
he said listen he wanted to be me
and all my fans disliked him for it they
said stop trying to copy the greatest of
all time you're never going to get there
and he didn't listen he just put his
head down and continued to do that
anyway because their games were so
similar
and so that to me was quite an admission
from the great michael jordan who who
obviously is going to be here this
weekend and
will stand up on stage with vanessa uh
to help
induct kobe into the hall of fame jackie
mcmullen here on the rich eisen show
again that piece is on espn plus
um the last communication between jordan
and bryant
you know and you know uh
it did hit me just the fact that he's
saving this right like he just won't
that's it yeah and it was sent in
december right it was right in your life
right
well i mean i i've lost people in your
life jackie i'll i'll share with you
since you just brought that up i was
literally sitting here thinking do i
share it i still have the last
i still have the last voicemail that my
dad sent me on my phone
and um you know i won't erase that
you know and it's it's oh you know and
so uh what what just walk me through
what you know
jordan's thought process of of keeping
it because obviously we all have that
sure
you know and it was sent to december
right the december before he passed
yeah it was december 8th right around
the holidays and jordan got a text said
uh it was right around afternoon time
about 12 18 and kobe said something like
well this tequila is awesome because you
know jordan had
started the sakura label with um
actually with genie bus
of the lakers and white grouse back of
the celtics and
wes edens of the box they had all kind
of combined to do this uh
this great tequila and he had sent kobe
a bottle of it at the launch and
so he said oh thanks you know you good
sure family good yep yep everybody's
good
and uh so jordan just got a real kick
out of the fact that kobe was coaching
gigi he just thought that was wonderful
and
like anything kobe does had really
thrown himself into it so he decided to
have a little fun
you know as he said so we'll catch you
know happy holidays and
what's this about coach kobe and he said
yeah
you know you know it man and he said i'm
sitting here on the bench right now
we're blowing them out 45 to 8.
and that was the last communication
between them and as
um as jordan said the reason i saved it
it's just typical kobe just
the competitive of him and how much
kobe had really wrapped himself up in
his family uh
in his retirement you know it's funny
when not funny but
when kobe pass i was skiing actually
with my family my daughter lives in
colorado and literally a stranger came
up to me on the mountain to tell me i
didn't know i had my phone in my
my ski jacket but i wasn't looking at it
i was on vacation and when he told me of
course i went inside my phone had blown
up so
i left them out and went home to write
and i started calling around
and so many of the the people that i
would have guessed kobe was sort of
close to said
you know i was close to him but really
he had thrown himself into his family
his circle was small
it was very very small and i remember i
texted michael
that day and i said look i know this is
really hard um what are you thinking
they said
too devastated i have no words because
he was part of that inner circle
it's kind of crazy too jackie though i i
just remember
because that was part of the last dance
of kobe
and madison square garden you know
waving carl malone off the blocks
at that all-star game right and right
and
and great moment but it it it was but
and how
you know at the time that the brashness
of kobe at the beginning and you're
you're
kind of pulling back the curtain a bit
about how he was reaching out to a bunch
of people including jordan but
you know at the time it it it was kind
of like you know he was
crashing away you know a goat party
you know and now he's getting into the
hall this weekend with jordan
posthumously inducting him and i'm i'm
wondering what you think kobe would
would think of the class going that he's
going in with
you know obviously not the matter but
what do you think if he would think of
this
best you can tell jackie well i think i
think he would be very pleased to go in
with someone like kg whose intensity was
off the charts much much like kobe's was
and then someone like tim duncan who had
a
sort of wiseness to the way he played
the game evolved over time into a
different player which is something kobe
did
i think he would have had great respect
for that i would argue this is the most
star-studded hall of fame class ever
with those three in it and uh so i think
he would have enjoyed his place in it
i think kobe would have stolen the show
even though he's not here he's gonna
steal the show
and you know that brassness you talked
about i really turned some guys off in
the beginning rich as you recall
including shaq you know shaq in the
beginning is like young hey young fellow
wait your turn
this is my team and you know shaq told
me very famously told me a story once
that
kobe was you know going out shooting hot
dogging and dale harris was the coach
and
pulled him out and sat him down the end
of the bench and one of um
jerry buss's friends came out of the
stands and said put him back in
i mean that's the kind of stuff they
were dealing with you know it was uh
and jordan's right he mentions in the
piece that you've referenced that
people forget it didn't happen all right
away for kobe he was not rookie of the
year averaging 30 minutes a game that's
not how it went
he had to wait his turn he had to you
know he played limited minutes
he had to earn it and he did and he did
it all on as an 18 year old kid
on a team with guys that were older
savvier
more mature and and and like to have
some fun at his expense
at times you know he was a kid and so
when you think about that and jordan
you know the word jordan used was
self-made i think it just makes you
admire
even more what he was able to accomplish
on the basketball court jackie mcmullen
here on the rich eisen show espn senior
writer
and um and also we see uh jackie on so
many espn shows
uh right here on the rich eisen show
what do you think jordan's speech is
gonna be like
what do you think well you know i'm not
sure in the end that michael's gonna be
the one doing the talking there's been
um
there's been talk now that perhaps
vanessa's going to do the actual talking
okay and uh i think jordan will probably
have some a little bit of sadness but
also release he was very
concerned about uh containing his
emotions as as everyone remembers at the
staples center memorial
you know jordan didn't couldn't contain
his emotions didn't even try
uh wept through the whole thing and i
would imagine it would be similar
here this weekend um so he may not end
up being
the person that speaks on behalf of kobe
it may be that his wife vanessa decides
to do that
but either way you know i just i just
got here a little while ago
and it's all anyone's talking about is
kobe the emotions of it
that someone dying so young and you know
the tragedy of that helicopter crashed
with so many people
died so young not just kobe not just
gigi right you know there were other
teenagers and young parents
on that flight the hell you know the
pilot was i don't think even 50 years
old i mean
a lot of people died young in that
during that tragedy and i always like to
mention the other people that lost their
lives today because their lives
are no less important than kobes or
gigi's and i think kobe and gigi would
be the first to say that well said
jackie mcmullen well said um and then
you know that that will obviously be
quite a remarkable moment
um and i'm assuming who else is going to
be there
who else are we hearing that's going to
be there for because this is also
two classes combined and so many people
who
want to be there and uh good to know
that the cdc has changed you know
uh made made their ruling on thursday
that maybe
more and more people might be more
comfortable coming now i don't know
last minute i'm just throwing all this
together yeah yeah i don't i don't think
that's possible rich this thing has been
planned for so long and
um i've you know i've been doubly
vaccinated for months but i had to still
present a negative cola test when i
checked in here today
okay add masks on everywhere uh you know
this is one of the most
coveted tickets probably in hall of fame
history in some regards
and because of cover they moved it out
of springfield to mahigan sun
where they can socially distance a
little more effectively okay uh you know
one of the great
events of uh enshrinement weekend is
they always have this
pre-ceremony cocktail party which is
just it's my favorite weekend because
you know you bump into sam jones and
oscar robertson and uh you know whomever
else uh
all you know spencer hayward who's a
regular here and just a terrific guy you
always are happy to see him
and uh and those those pre-ceremony
receptions are gonna be split up into
six different restaurants
you can't even have everybody all in the
same place so it's going to be a very
different feel to it
um but you know when the at when the
actual enshrinement
ceremony happens on saturday everybody's
going to be under one roof and it's
it's i'm really looking forward to it
and i'm going to be there as a spectator
on saturday not as a journalist i'm
going to be there as
uh what you know witnessing three guys
that i covered closely
rudy tom janovich of course oh boy who i
also
um you know covered extensively and i'm
so happy for him to get in
the great tamika catchings is getting in
and then someone that people should know
more about her name is barbara stevens
week older cardinal barty stevens
she was the bentley college coach in um
west in
waltham mass not far at all from where i
grew up actually
she actually recruited my sister when
she was at clark university in worcester
so i've been following barbara's career
for many years
very well deserved she's got over a
thousand career wins she's probably the
name people don't know but should know
from this class too she's well deserved
to be part of this you know really elite
group it's it's going to be fantastic
i'm really looking forward to it i'm
glad you've given me that perspective
jackie i just
i'll be honest i just got a really
emotional hearing you mentioned tamika
catchings for some reason
and that is also just fantastic right
well she's not only
fantastic but the fact is that
you know kobe being a girl dad and
and what what what what women's and
girls basketball
meant to him as well certainly
in the final years of his life i i think
he would be
like over the moon that he's going in
with right
you know the only thing that's bad is
because of covenant because this
this ceremony had to be delayed it's
normally in september
you know the nba is in full throttle
here so for instance
and i haven't talked to doc so i don't
know doc rivers has a game today and
then he has a game
on sunday is he going to try to you know
scoot in here to be here for kg is it
even possible does it make any sense
because you know doc would love to be
here i don't know if i've ever talked to
doc rivers about kg without him choking
up that's how much he feels
and of course seriously they just you
know he knows that kg
was the heart and soul of that 2008
championship team and then now you've
got greg popovich and i haven't looked
at their schedule but
greg papaji and tim duncan were
synonymous with one another
probably similar to tom brady and bill
belichick and there's a very good chance
i'm guessing he can't possibly get here
because
i'm looking at saturday's schedule and
phoenix is at san antonio i mean it's a
pretty
it's not going to happen significant
game in the western conference standings
and then
well that's the way that's the only
theme of it you know
it normally this event is held when the
nba is idle
right and it's a shame because i think
more players you know current players
would have loved to have been here so
many of them revered kobe so much you
know from
i mean name them kevin durant kyrie
irving all those guys
they've they've spoken eloquently how
much uh kobe meant to them
jamal murray i did a story tomorrow
murray earlier
in the year and he was talking about
being invited to kobe's camp and how it
was just a life-changing experience for
him so
i think many of those guys uh chris paul
a lot another one
if they could be there they would but
they can't you know this is the final
weekend of a really
bizarre nba season where playing games
are matter and
almost no team hardly any teams are out
of it and so it's uh
you know won't be quite the same well
i'll help you out on this one there's
just two
sixers home games wrapped around the
ceremony and if i if
protocols can do it right if protocols
can be followed maybe doc will do it and
it's interesting on saturday boston at
minnesota so two kg
franchises that he's so synonymous with
will pl they're playing each other
before i let you go give me i mean
duncan's speech is there an over under
like less than five minutes
you got that for me don't you know it's
going to be the most hilarious one of
all
my over under is what is he going to
wear i mean he's not going to wear a
tuxedo right is he going to wear a suit
and tie is he going to button up for us
this one time
i don't know i can't wait i mean there's
i'm
tim duncan to me is endlessly
fascinating because he's so tremendously
talented but also just because he was
just such a quiet
superstar and never really gets to do in
my opinion is he the greatest power
forward of all time
you can make that case the big
fundamental yeah so um yeah you know and
then uh
last one kg speech like that one uh
i i need to you know find out if i can
you know
see that one live so right you know
you shouldn't get close to it because
like you might get this fiddle it might
be in your face you know
he only does things fast and furious
that's the only way he knows how to go
about things so
i think it'll all be it's all going to
be great jackie i appreciate the insight
again a beautiful piece that you wrote
about kobe and jordan and let's uh
i'd love to have you back on uh during
the playoffs let's let's talk some hoops
let's do it thanks thank you enjoy the
weekend
jackie mcmullen here a senior writer and
contributor and comment
tater for espn and analyst right here
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here